le fait de ceux de prétendre sans cesse
être censuré ne renvoie pas forcément à
une réalité mais il est toujours très
avantageux d'un point de vue rhétorique
de se présenter comme censure et a
fortiori qu'on voulait pas réellement
c'est à dire que se prétendre censure et
c'est finalement une manière aussi
d'échapper à la discussion et à la
critique et vous avez tout à fait raison
je pense qu'en fait aujourd'hui les
frontières de la liberté d'expression
sont largement autant dessiné par la loi
et par les juges que par des mécanismes
privé qui échappe sans fait très
largement à la compréhension des gens et
des utilisateurs notamment les
plateformes puisqu'on commence
aujourd'hui à réfléchir et analyser à la
façon dont des plateformes effectivement
réguler leur contenu selon des normes
qui sont parfois un petit peu opaque et
surtout des mécanismes qui sont un petit
peu opaque et donc là on va forcément
voir arriver ce sera intéressant à
constater des manières de contourner
tout ça est la question ce sera plus
forcément comment on contourne la loi
comme on contourne un juge mais comment
contourner un algorithme et on peut se
demander à quoi ça va ressembler
[Musique]